spring is here and it's time to gather
up those spring essentials and i'm so
excited that lifestyle expert samantha
vickers is back to tell us what we need
to have to get back into the season
welcome back thank you so much i love
being here and i love seeing you
you're always our go-to expert when it
comes to lifestyle stuff and what we
need especially as we get back into the
season so let's talk about our must-have
items and this first one i love i see
you're wearing one and i love a piece of
jewelry but i especially love a piece of
jewelry if it keeps me cool in this las
vegas heat absolutely so these are hot
girls pearls and this is specifically
their cooling chiclet bracelet and i
love this because it comes with this
cute little pouch and there's actually
ice packs around that you put your
bracelet in that pouch in the freezer
for four hours and then it's going to
keep you nice and cool when you wear it
because inside of this is gel that's
freezable and so gonna keep you nice and
cool this is the perfect city for these
things i'm telling you and i'm wearing
this i can tell it's been refrigerated
it's nice and cool and just what a
refreshing thing to wear while you're
laying by the pool and look look nice i
know yeah nobody's gonna know that you
have an ice pack on your wrist i love
this this is you could even wear it as
an anklet if you really want to keep
them totally good
is cool too i love this and these are at
hotgirlspearls.com and they also have
necklaces so yeah go check them out
bracelets necklaces and they'll keep you
cool in the summer in the spring this is
one of those things where it's like why
didn't i think of that that's a great
idea i know all right speaking of summer
we want to stay hydrated we want to stay
hydrated and i brought hydrolyte and
specifically the electrolyte powder
sticks because these things are super
convenient you can take them anywhere
and they're not going to have all of the
icky stuff that some other electrolyte
powders have and so i love hydrolyte and
they're really convenient you can grab
them at cvs rite aid or you can go on to
their website at hydrate
hydrolyte
calm we're going to hydrate with
hydrolyzed yes and maybe you just need a
little extra um maybe you had a couple
of drinks a night before exactly
throw that in your water bottle it's
great for the gym it's great for the
office a night out on the town you know
the next day you want to we're 75 of us
are dehydrated and especially in this
city you don't want that you don't want
that so you need to get hydrated you
need to be able to have these cute
little sticks they dissolve instantly so
easy to throw in your purse wherever
you've got them i love that okay this is
a really cool invention and i'm gonna
try and put this on because you were
describing this to me what is this
called and how does it work okay so this
is called cove and it is like a hug for
your mind so what it is is it's wearable
technology that uses gentle vibrations
to mimic human touch and so if it's used
consistently what happens is you start
to have improved sleep um reduce stress
and it actually makes the wear more
resilient because you're more self-aware
so it hooks around your ears but then
it's actually the back of your ear right
here that the vibrations and you you
can't feel them it's pretty
imperceptible and it just kind of like
mimics the touch
and you know we all need more touch we
all need that soothing and that calm so
yeah you can wear it while you're making
dinner or anything like that and you can
go to philcove.com to get that one what
a neat idea i love that all right and i
always need a good hack from you sam you
always have the best packs so give it to
me what's spring cleaning what are we
doing cleaning that's right so this is
just plain old white vinegar okay so add
a half a cup of white vinegar to the
rinse cycle on your laundry okay it's
going to help to remove stains keep your
colors bright it's going to help to get
rid of that soapy residue that our
clothes sometimes have on them so that's
a great laundry hack this one is
actually my favorite so this is how you
clean your microwave without any elbow
grease so you're going to get a
microwavable bowl fill it halfway with
water i have a whole lemon that i've cut
in half i put in here put that in your
microwave for three minutes on high then
let it sit for another five minutes to
steam up yeah then you're gonna go ahead
and just remove this from the microwave
take the turntable out and all you have
to do is wipe it clean it's not no elbow
grease required and it's going to smell
great you just saved me a ton of work
i'm going to i'm going to throw some
flour in my face and act like i slaved
around in the kitchen all day long
best stuff ever thank you how do people
reach you if they want more tips in some
of these products yeah they can always
find me at samanthavickers.com and come
follow me on social media send me a
message which one did you like the best
what do you what are you going to use oh
we love it